[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez esta vez con la
vicepresidencia colombiana como telón de
fondo lugar que por primera vez en la
historia es ocupado por una mujer
afrocolombiana el motivo es en la
celebración del Día Internacional de la
niña que se lleva a cabo cada 11 de
octubre y que es una fecha instaurada
por la ONU con la esperanza de una
restitución de derechos y de que todas
las niñas en el mundo puedan vivir
libres de violencia
vicepresidenta por un día
en un acto simbólico en Bogotá capital
colombiana ayelén fue recibida por
Francia Márquez defensora de derechos
humanos y primera mujer afrocolombiana
en llegar al segundo cargo del Ejecutivo
en el país latinoamericano el mensaje es
simple una niña puede y necesita soñar
con estar en los lugares donde se toman
las decisiones ella como todas merece
ser escuchada como le dijo la propia
Francia antes de posesionarla las
mujeres no podemos tener miedo de estar
en el poder
ancestra hasta que la dignidad se haga
posible
si así lo hicieras
que Dios y la patria o su premio sino él
y ella os lo demanda
con una de niña es el nombre de la
campaña materializada por la fundación
en plan organización que en el día de la
niña llevó a varias jóvenes a ejercer
los cargos de las altas funcionarias de
Colombia en su reunión de gabinete
ayelén se sentó rodeada de sus ministros
vulnerar nuestros derechos porque
nosotros las niñas somos capaces de
cumplir sueños planteo cuestiones
sencillas pero fundamentales en un país
con un largo prontuario de violencia y
discriminación
[Aplausos]
la tarea de las adultas fue escuchar y
responder en el marco de un gobierno que
ha prometido un enfoque de Derechos
Humanos
tenemos toda la intención y ayudarle en
el desarrollo de su gobierno de sus
programas sobre todo enfocados a
garantizar los derechos de los niños
de las mujeres para acabar con la
violencia
mujeres y las niñas en este país el Día
Internacional de la niña promueve un
mundo libre de violencias de género
donde las mujeres y las juventudes
puedan gozar de sus derechos sin embargo
lejos de esa realidad en Colombia en
2021 Aproximadamente a 44 niñas y
adolescentes sufrieron violencia sexual
a diario siendo el 81% del total de las
víctimas
en 2021 se registraron 13 nacimientos
diariamente de niñas menores de 14 años
los cuales son producto de la violación
pese a la normalización de prácticas
como el matrimonio infantil el país suma
en la pandemia de la discriminación por
nacer mujer solo por poner un ejemplo
casi una de cada cuatro jóvenes de entre
15 y 19 años en todo el mundo no reciben
educación empleo Capacitación en
comparación con uno de cada diez niños y
la lista de desigualdades sigue en todos
los aspectos de la vida y ahora es el
momento de tener la conversación en ella
soy sobre los derechos de las niñas esta
vez enfocados en Colombia como ha sido
durante todo este programa y para ello
me acompaña clemencia caravaggio ella es
alta consejera presidencial en Colombia
por la equidad y la mujer clemencia
Gracias por estar con nosotros en ella
sola muchas gracias a ustedes por
facilitar este espacio gracias por la
invitación bien clemencia solamente le
voy a hacer algunas preguntas con el
tiempo que nos permite el programa y
quisiera empezar por las cifras entre
12.000 y 15.000 niñas son Víctimas de
violencia sexual en Colombia Cómo
llegamos hasta este epidemia Y qué es lo
que ustedes están planteando que se va a
hacer de ahora en adelante cuando
sabemos que en Colombia hay un completo
cambio de enfoque bueno Efectivamente es
una lástima que en Colombia haya tantas
afectaciones a las niñas especialmente
que son nuestro presente y el futuro de
nuestro país y justamente de este
gobierno que no nos hemos propuesto
trabajar por el cambio por garantizar
derechos a toda la población colombiana
de manera especial desde la Desde la
distancia que yo dirijo la consejería
presidencial para la actividad de la
mujer nos proponemos trabajar con las
mujeres con la familia para garantizar
entornos protectores para las niñas para
todas las niñas del país
y entre las entre las líneas de trabajo
que tiene la consejería Pues tenemos la
línea de trabajo de violencia contra las
mujeres allí tenemos toda una estrategia
que permita acciones de inclusión
acciones de información de
sensibilización de garantía de entornos
protectores para que las niñas no solo
tengan mayores acceso a la educación
a la ciencia la tecnología a Innovación
sino también mayores acceso en general a
sus derechos bueno y uno de los temas
que preocupan Precisamente en este caso
señora clemencia ese el tema de los
renacimientos de las niñas que se
convierten en madres Son miles y miles
de niñas que se convierten cada año en
Colombia en madres siendo adolescentes
muchas de ellas menores de 14 años
En qué consisten estos planes para
taclear los nacimientos o las
maternidades no deseadas que también
usted lo sabe pues afectan temas de
pobreza de Educación perpetúa en las
cadenas de violencia en Colombia total
los temas de y también los temas de
digamos madres cabeza de familia tiene
que ver precisamente con eso con que hay
que fortalecer los temas de formación
los temas de información de Educación
desde la escuela desde la casa hay que
digamos orientar a nuestras niñas a
nuestros niños y sobre todo creo que hay
que atacar un fenómeno de lo que tiene
que ver con matrimonios a veces pues no
deseados especialmente entre niñas
jóvenes entre adolescentes Claro en
Colombia está normalizado todavía el
matrimonio infantil todavía se permita
que una niña que tiene 14 años se case y
nadie dice nada Y eso es violencia
también claro eso es violencia y
precisamente yo creo que la normatividad
Colombia tiene que revisarse a la luz de
garantizar derechos porque lo lo digamos
lo lógico es que un adolescente una niña
esté pensando en estudiar esté pensando
en desarrollar su proyecto de vida y
cuidar un bebé Sí entonces creo que la
legislación colombiana tiene que también
ser una especie de entorno protector
para estas niñas Así que parte de lo que
pues Tendremos que hacer desde la
consejería con nuestra línea de trabajo
de feminización de la del estado es
revisar junto con
el congreso de Colombia las leyes que
garantizan derechos a las mujeres a las
niñas y a las niñas en este país cosa
que hasta el momento no ha pasado porque
la justicia no está a favor de las
mujeres el sistema judicial no lo está
no lo están las entidades estatales o no
ha sido así históricamente qué es lo que
ustedes están haciendo para implantar
muy claramente un enfoque de género en
el tratamiento de los casos de niños y
adolescentes en este caso bueno en
primer lugar estamos incidiendo a través
del diálogo de la coordinación con las
diferentes instancias responsables del
tema incluido pues la la los la El
Congreso de Colombia las instituciones
que trabajan por la niñez bienestar
familiar Las digamos
los entes los otros gentes del Estado
responsables de garantizar los derechos
de las niñas y los niños para que
trabaja haciendo un trabajo articulado
podamos incidir en que haya una política
digamos más adecuada que garantice pues
esos derechos yo creo que
hay que avanzar y justamente pues este
es el gobierno del cambio y es parte de
las cosas que tenemos que cambiar Bueno
y los medios de comunicación estamos
aquí para hacer esa sabiduría y
verificar esos cambios que se están
prometiendo yo creo que no es
soloveduría yo creo que los medios de
comunicación también juegan un papel
importante en la educación del país en
la educación de la gente en la educación
de la población y creo que los medios
también deben de Aliado para esta labor
de sensibilización de educar y de
informar muy bien y ya que estamos
llegando al final de este programa se
nos va acabando el tiempo que quiero
preguntarle por qué Para ustedes no solo
indispensable es casi una obligación una
una necesidad que las niñas sueñen con
estar en el poder sueñan con estar en
los lugares en los que se toman
decisiones lo que está pasando hoy con
la vicepresidencia de Colombia es
inédito para el país con una mujer
afrodescendiente activista que está
asumiendo un cargo de poder y que está
invitando a las que vienen detrás de
ella para que también asuman cargos de
poder lo que está pasando con usted como
consejera presidencial
los sueños el primer paso para lograr
cambios Entonces si nosotras las mujeres
hemos estado afectadas por tantas
acciones que violentan nuestros derechos
pues tenemos que soñar con cambiarnos y
parte de eso tiene que ver con poder
estar en instancias de poder para gestar
el cambio desde nosotros las mujeres y
para nosotros las mujeres Entonces es
muy importante este ejercicio
especialmente hoy en el día de la niña
poder que ellas vean que si es posible
que los sueños que sus proyectos de vida
que ellas tienen para cambiar su
comunidad para cambiar su vida para
cambiar su país es son posibles entonces
creo que que es muy importante que ellas
pues se los se sueñen siempre un mejor
futuro porque a partir del sueño se
puede hacer realidad pues clemencia el
agradecimiento es para ustedes y también
pues o para nuestros televidentes como
siempre por estar con nosotros en ellas
hoy y en Francia 24 nos vemos
Próximamente y muchas gracias gracias a
ustedes